[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et ravi de vous retrouver
ce soir dans point de vue je vous
présente sans plus tarder nos deux
invités
bonsoir claire chartier vous êtes
rédactrice en chef des pages idées de
l'express votre hebdomadaire consacre
cette semaine sa couverture à l'épidémie
avec cette signal d'alarmé face à
l'épidémie
arrêtons les erreurs et c'est une
interview d'un professeur de médecine et
spa en pointe sur ce sujet vous est
aussi l'auteur d'un livre sur un sujet
grave le viol et nous enquête sur un
fléau social publié aux édition de
l'observatoire
bonsoir gabriel plus elle vous est
rédactrice en chef du site boulevard
voltaire vous êtes aussi essayiste
vous collaborez à l'hebdomadaire famille
chrétienne est votre dernier livre
enracinée nous sommes tous d héritier a
été publiée chez artège on commence si
vous le voulez bien avec un sujet
politique
il se il s'est confirmé ce matin que
françois baroin ne serait pas le
représentant des républicains pour 2022
il ne sera pas candidat à l'élection
présidentielle ce n'est pas forcément
une surprise en tout cas pas pour les
lecteurs du figaro puisque notre
consoeur marion mourgue avait déjà signé
un papier
affirmatif sur ce sujet il ya plus d'un
mois c'était le 4 septembre
pourquoi baroin ne sera pas candidat en
tout cas ça se confirme ça laisse donc
de la place pour les autres
à la fois à l'intérieur des républicains
et puis dans cette famille politique au
sens large et parmi ceux qui ne cachent
pas leurs ambitions
bruno retailleau le président du groupe
l air au sénat il était ce matin sur
france inter
et j'ai toujours indiqué que j'ai des
convictions je lés portes et que je les
défendrai malheureusement ce que je vais
dire être candidat ça veut dire que s'il
faut candidat je le serai
malheureusement je vois bien que mon
propre parti fait tout pour tuer la
primaire moi je verrai ce qu'il se passe
je risque le font les yeux doux à xavier
bertrand sur sûr c'est une abdication
total ils veulent se passer des
militants ils veulent se passer des
sympathisants moi je veux être le
porte-voix de la droite d'en bas parce
que il y en a marre des petits
arrangements des petits as commandement
de la droite dans ou et voilà la droite
française telle qu'en elle-même je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas tel qu'on l'a
déjà connu c'est à dire se divisant
notamment sur ce sujet du critères de
désignation du candidat faut-il passer
par une primaire comme le souhaite bruno
retailleau ou bien faire émerger un
candidat entre guillemets naturelles par
exemple par les élections régionales
c'est en tout cas la stratégie que
défend xavier bertrand qui est un autre
candidat et qui est aussi candidat à sa
réélection à la présidence des hauts de
france alors 18 mois avant l'élection
c'est difficile de savoir s'il ya des
favoris ou non surtout que les deux que
je viens de citer ne sont pas les seuls
candidats il ya aussi la présidente de
la région ile de france qui ne cache pas
ses ambitions valérie pécresse mais
aussi rachida dati qui est candidate
quasiment officiellement et qui pourrait
faire un pas de plus dans cette
direction
vendredi c'est à dire après demain dans
un déplacement à reims
voyons juste pour fixer les idées
ce petit sondage qui va c'est pas un
petit sondage ce sondage qui encore une
fois vaut ce qu'il vaut
car l'élection c'est pour 2022 si c'est
bertrand retailleau qui alors on va
commencer par xavier bertrand
si c'est ça va tellement vite que c'est
formidable vous avez vu les deux donc si
ces bourgs si c'est xavier bertrand on y
arrive qui est le candidat de la droite
selon un sondage ifop fiducial publié
par le jdd dimanche dernier eh bien il
arriverait troisième au premier tour
et puis autres hypothèses testées celle
avec bruno retailleau qui lui serait ta
8%
gabriel cluzel elle qui serait selon
vous le meilleur candidat pour la droite
alors on dit souvent
retailleau c'est bien parce que le coeur
des militants l air le suivraient mais
xavier bertrand se seraient peut-être
encore mieux parce qu'il rassemblerait
plus c'est à dire que bruno retailleau
et xavier bertrand sont représentatifs
finalement du grand dilemme de l air
chacun dans leur genre puisque
finalement la maison et l'eire qui a été
créé au moment de la guerre froide une
belle maison avec encore des beaux
bijoux de famille d'avions municipale
des beaux meubles et puis elle est il se
trouve qu'elle est sur une faille
sismique si j'ose dire il ya un
mouvement de tectonique des plaques qui
fait qu'il ya une partie qui s'éloigne
partie plus conservatrice et plus
identitaire qui s'éloigne vers le
rassemblement national dit en tout cas
qui est un petit peu en écoute les
sirènes du rassemblement national et une
autre qui s'éloigne s'écarte vert
emmanuel macron et en l'occurrence c'est
bien et xavier bertrand c'est la partie
10 non plus macron compatibles même je
sais pas s'il me laisserais dire mais
néanmoins c'est comme ça que le
perçoivent un certain nombre de gens et
puis bruno retailleau
c'est la partie c'est un peu l'héritier
de fillon un puisqu'il en a été le le
camarade de bataille durant durant un
moment donc c'est aussi la veine bellamy
alors c'est vrai que il va falloir il va
falloir faire faire un choix
bruno retailleau il est déjà en campagne
il en appelle à la raho à la france d'en
bas ça veut dire que au delà de son côté
conservateur il veut développer ce côté
populiste et puis se souvient aussi
peut-être de la petite percée qu'avait
fait je ne sais pas si vous vous
souvenez jean frédéric poisson au moment
ultraconservateur ce qu'il en est au
moment des primaires qui avaient eu
partie le patron du pc était en anglais
mme primaire de la droite qui avait
réussi à percer simplement par son
charisme personnel par c'est un petit
peu à sa mesure et donc bruno retailleau
fait ce pari là ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'à un moment elle erre va devoir
choisir moi je me ce qui me frappe c'est
cette phrase de vous savez du conseiller
de bush qui s'appelait je crois karl
rove et qui disait c'est pas la peine
d'aller chercher les voix de
l'adversaire il faut déjà convaincre
ceux qui vivent ce qu'ils pensent comme
nous de voter effectivement pour nous la
question est de savoir c'est que
pense-t-il réellement sheller et ou dans
quelle direction donc faut-il faut-il
aller chercher et là je crois que sur ce
plan là c'est pas très clair clash
artistes et parce qu'un sujet de
dissertation celui qui peut l'emporter
est-ce que c'est celui qui a les idées
les plus forts qui parle aux au coeur
nucléaire
son électorat ou celui qui rassemble le
plus on rappellera que xavier bertrand a
quitté les républicains et qu' il dirige
la région des hauts de france avec la
gauche qui avait retiré ses candidats au
second tour pour bloquer le passage au
rassemblement national le pen
mais c'est vrai que regarder les
sondages on se dit quand même que la
droite a plus de chance avec la droite
sociale de incarné par xavier bertrand
que la droite morale classique
traditionnelle et voir identitaire
effectivement de bonheur d'ayo parce que
bon bruno retailleau évoque tout à fait
la ligne de xavier bellamy qui sait
quand même qu'il a quand même donné à la
droite son gadin historique du point de
vue électoral aux européennes à peu près
8 % un peu plus de vie pour risquer
jamais la droite ne s'était autant
fracassé dans une élection donc c'est
vrai que cette ligne là paraît
aujourd'hui extrêmement périlleuse et en
plus en terme de chiffres comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure avec le sondage
elle est quand même très minoritaire
c'est à dire que xavier bertrand fait le
double de nos retailleau donc ça déjà
c'est quand même un problème ensuite sur
eux sur l'orientation l'orientation le
choix c'est vrai que bruno retailleau
incarne une ligne très classique
identitaire qui effectivement est
l'objet des convoitises d'url notamment
de marion le pen c'est plus vers cette
famille là que la le croisement pourrait
se faire donc marion maréchal-le pen
briques ce genre de profil pour faire
cette fameuse union de la droite qu'elle
appelle de ses voeux
donc là il ya une forme de porosité mais
je pense que là sur ce point-là
stratégiquement ceux qui sont sur cette
ligne là ils vont davantage vers
le rn plutôt que vers enfin logiquement
on préfère toujours et sans le dis tout
le temps mais c'est pas faux le produit
original à la copie
donc pourquoi finalement adopté un
monory taille aussi on peut choisir arn
donc il ya ce premier point
et puis ensuite je pense qu'il ya un
espace à jouer pour xavier bertrand par
rapport à maquereau il veut absolument
pas il le dire il se démarque de macron
etc
il a une ligne qui donc peut être un
avantage pour la droite qui est une
droite sociale empathique et peut-être
qu on y reviendra mais qui est
précisément le bât qui blesse chez
macron c'est à dire il brigue
ils arrivent à attirer des voix de
droite par son son discours beaucoup
plus conservateur d'une certaine manière
qu'au début de son quinquennat 2005 à
qena mais en revanche il manque
considérablement d'empathie pour les
souffrances de la classe moyenne ressort
qu'active considérablement vous aviez
bertrand est ainsi que nos internautes
ont l'air d'en penser plus tôt pour
bruno retailleau plus ou posant la
question sur twitter mais vous pouvez
encore voter et faire bouger ce score 60
% considèrent que c'est le président du
groupe l air au sénat qui serait le
meilleur leader de la droite pour 2022
et puis paysans sur twitter nous
rappelle ce que ce que tu dis que c'est
leur que bertrand a quitté l air et il
ajoute il n'est pas de droite il s'est
allié à la gauche pour sa région
d'ailleurs de gauche il est peut-être
aussi xavier bertrand sur le plan
économique il est par exemple
extrêmement virulent s'opposant à toutes
les fermetures d'usinés dans sa région
est donc en quelque sorte se montrant
aussi peu libérale que possible ça on a
tous un handicap
oui on sent qu'il veut m
une dose de terroir dans ce sens sa
campagne il joue la carte de l'assureur
de province qui l'a été voilà ce maxi de
noms mais je reste ils sont travaillés
au conseil régional
et puis ce côté notable rond surtout
dans tous les sens du terme de de la
france périphérique si j'ose dire est
donc il
il accentue ce côté là par ses prises de
position ce qu'il ya c'est xavier
bertrand est ce que ça va suffire pour
faire la différence avec emmanuel macron
c'est pas certain
le problème c'est que en effet il semble
être apparemment mieux placés à court
terme simplement à moyen terme il risque
de se poursuivre et je pense qu'un
certain nombre de gens sheller le voit
alors c'est peut-être inéluctable c'est
peut-être un parti qui est qui est
destiné à mourir je n'en sais rien mais
à ceux siphonnage engagé par emmanuel
macron faute de clivage suffisant faute
de de se démarquer suffisamment
d'emmanuel macron et ça pour les as
l'air sain c1 c'est un danger non nous
voilà non négligeable bruno retailleau
il a vous avez raison il attire une
droite plus conservatrice et nous
l'avons dit plus identitaire il a
quelques handicaps notamment son
animosité avec philippe de villiers qui
connut et c'est vrai clip de lier reste
une figure force de cette droite là et
lié à l'heure à leur différend vendéen
par ailleurs à que phillies et considère
que bruno retailleau l'a trahie alors
même qu'il était vraiment un petit trait
une série très proche et il est
notamment parce que c'est un poste
gouvernemental
exactement et puis l'autre point qui
sera peut-être la faiblesse de bruno
retailleau qui a peut-être été celle de
françois xavier mal mais alors là aussi
sa manie avec précaution parce que vous
disiez wina il a fait que 8 % il s'est
pris une gifle gigantesque peut-être que
ça aurait été une autre ligne ça aurait
pu être encore pire parce que là elle n
est pas entré n'était pas en très bonne
santé au moment des européennes
non le problème et c'est vrai que c'est
à mon avis un piège dans lequel est
empêtré cette droite conservatrice qui
essaie d'être un peu plus populistes et
et identitaire c'est que et bien elle
reste elle veut garder ce cordon
sanitaire qu'a dressé en son temps
françois mitterrand avec avec la droite
donc elle se refuse absolument à toute
alliance avec le rassemblement national
or l'électorat lui c'est vrai qu'il en
appelle à l électorat bruno retailleau
mais l'électorat précisément lui voit
cette porosité vous avez parlé de marion
maréchal il se sent assez proche de
marée noire et c'est donc par exemple
quand il a vu françois fillon ces
résultats les taux oui non mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que précisément de ce
fait il aura du mal à récupérer cet
électorat pas ce qu'on pourrait imaginer
que l air est un peu est passé du côté
du rassemblement national un peu écoeuré
par cette fausse droite comme on
l'appelle au rassemblement national donc
on pourrait imaginer qu'un
françois-xavier mais un ami ou un bruno
retailleau réussissent à terme à la
récupérer le problème c'est que il faut
instaurer un climat de confiance qui
n'est pas là et pourquoi il n'est pas là
c'est par exemple françois fillon très
rapidement au deuxième tour des
présidentielles
on a l'impression qu'il n'a même pas
pris le temps de réfléchir il était
devant le plateau télévision il s'était
pas écoulé cinq minutes il a dit
j'appelle à voter emmanuel au soir du
premier foyer un nul ça a fortement
troublé il ya eu un petit peu le même
phénomène si je peux me permettre avec
de une minute avec françois-xavier
bellamy au moment des législatives il
était sur le versailles alors c'est vrai
que c'est un peu plus c'est un peu
complexe puisque versailles et rajouter
à d'autres communes il n'y a pas un
versailles total donc c'est pas le
versailles catholique et conservateur
qui était sur sa secret circonscription
totalité mais en réalité il a perdu le
vote est reine à versailles pour une
raison absolument tout simple c'est
qu'il a je pense si je crois pas trop
m'avancer c'est qu'il ya eu une tribune
dans le figaro dans lequel il a dit
finalement à peu ou prou tous sauf
marine le pen
c'était juste avant les présidentielles
vous savez que les législatives suivez
les présidentielles et donc ça a
fortement troubler l'électorat
rassemblement national qui de ce fait
peine à se rapprocher d'un bruno
retailleau oudin france examine et à le
croire en se disant mais finalement
quand ils ont à choisir entre les deux
on comprend qu'il soit différent du
rassemblement national très bien c'est
d'ailleurs pour cela qu'on votera pour
eux mais quand ils ont à choisir entre
emmanuel macron et le rassemblement
social il préféré à emmanuel macron
alors que nous on se sent plus proche
c'est ce que pensent les électorats les
cet électorat du rassemblement national
donc ça les troubles et cette espèce de
jeu à double bande en zigzag empêche je
pense à certains nombres de l air
conservateur de revenir au foyer ou
alors j'ai pas l'impression enfin est-ce
que les nerfs conservateur donc qu'ils
sont aussi nombreux que ça parmi les
élèves c'est une interrogation par
rapport à l'électorat et l'eire qui est
aussi composée de deux classes moyennes
d'ingénieurs d'agriculteurs qui sont
deux centristes qui sont très frappé par
un précisément la spirale de
déclassement aujourd'hui encore plus
avec locaux vides je suis pas sûr qu'un
bruno retailleau répondent à cette
sensibilité là il ya un autre des
avantages qui n'est pas négligeable du
tout c'est que nicolas sarkozy ne veut
pas entendre parler de lui et que
nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui c'est si ce
n'est le deus ex machina de la droite
c'est le sait au moins le grand le grand
sage que l'on consulte pour un os dur
pour savoir vers quel vent se tourner
donc c'est un gros handicap et
un petit point je sens assez xavier
bertrand en accord avec un aurélien
pradié par exemple secrétaire général de
l air donc il ya aussi quand même là une
passerelle est en tout cas un vivier de
voix potentielles qui le lest comme
candidat crédible pour nos internautes
réagissent merci à eux
philippe sur twitter retailleau est un
vrai candidat de droite avec un
mouvement en progression donc c'est
peut-être pas philippe de villiers même
on n'a pas son nom de famille
retailleau est un vrai candidat de
droite avec un mouvement en progression
un programme une assise au sénat et
l'expérience de la campagne de françois
fillon en 2016
notre cher babineau considère lui que
bertrand ferait un très bon ministre ou
premier ministre mâcon compatibles mais
qu'il n'est pas en mesure de contrarier
le duel macron le pen chardon bleu les
médias veulent à tout prix de coller
bertrand mais on n'en veut pas et il
ajoute par contre retailleau vaut une
primaire ouverte et je ne crois pas que
ce soit une bonne idée bombe alors on
n'est pas complètement sorti de
l'auberge
quelques instants pour regarder la
couverture de ce livre qui va sortir la
semaine prochaine il est signé pierre de
villiers
vous savez c'est l'ancien chef d'état
major des armées qui avait été limogé
dans des conditions assez tonique par le
président de la république
un nouveau livre l'équilibré est un
courage et un sous titre réparer la
france il ya des gens qui disent que ça
pourrait faire un bon candidat de la
société civile susceptible de séduire
toute la droite quand pensez-vous
gabriel plus elle est amusante par les
sociétés civiles pour un militaire mais
c'est vrai donc comparé au monde
politique sont en effet quelqu'un de la
société civile nous j'ai remarqué sur le
site boulevard voltaire nous avions fait
une bonne petite un petit sondage est
donc une droite assez conservatrice qui
répondaient ils étaient arrivés premiers
il talonnait marion maréchal voilà et
donc il ya un certain nombre de gens qui
croient en lui je crois que c'est un
double phénomène le premier c'est que
l'armée donne le sentiment aujourd'hui
d'être à un endroit ou de le dernier
endroit d'unité nationale et puis où le
un des derniers endroits elle un endroit
où le bien commun existe encore c'est
vrai que emmener des hommes à une mort
potentiel et qui accepte de sacrifier
leur vie parce que ils ont pour un comme
andy rihs cause qu'ils imitent ils
pensent supérieur qui la patrie c'est
devenu rare en ces temps d'un
individualisme donc je pense que l'armée
véhicule beaucoup d'espérance s'est
aussi une réussite de d'assimilation aux
parents d'aller lui personnellement leur
grand façon générale et lui c'est vrai
que au moment de son départ cette façon
de ruer dans les brancards et bien les
gens se sont dit voilà quelqu'un qui en
plus est capable de pour protéger les
siens puisque c'était en l'occurrence
pour défendre l'institution militaire
il est capable de sacrifier sa fin de
carrière pour tout est relatif à ce
qu'il avait déjà une belle carrière
derrière lui donc les gens l'ont été
extrêmement admiratif alors c'est vrai
qu'en france on quand on attend on
commence à parler des généraux c'est une
des militaires c'est que ça faisait va
pas très bien il est un fait que la
situation n'est pas très bonne et puis
aussi il faut pas se le cacher il ya le
nom villiers derrière qui véhiculent
dans une certaine droite un imaginaire
c'est le puy du fou
alors quel quidam affaire de feeling et
le frère de philippe douillard quand on
lit les
livre de pierre de villiers ce ne sont
pas les livres de de philippe de
villiers soit soyons très clairs c'est
pas du tout le même genre de douvres âge
on n'est plus dans la gestion des hommes
et moins dans le nez plus quand je vois
que vous utilisez un mot qui a été
utilisée récemment par un chroniqueur
célèbre à son sujet oui mais peut-être
parce que l'institution militaire
apprend en effet être allée de politique
et à ménager les uns et les autres
d'ailleurs sa faiblesse serait à mon
avis et pour tout militaire ce serait
sans doute la même chose c'est que je ne
dis pas que la guerre se fait en
dentelle mais le comment dirais-je les
laits les l'institution militaire est un
endroit où on est relativement loyal ou
où il n'y a pas cessé les jolis sourires
tous les coups ne sont pas permis merci
à un mot là-dessus peut-être changement
qu'il incarne effectivement là le
dévouement l'ordre aussi une certaine
forme de hiérarchie et de est dans un
monde qui dans une société qui va un peu
vers le
qui semble aller vers le chaos c'est
assez rassurant bon cela dit lui n'est
pas du tout candidat
et puis il a une bonne image aussi au
sein des armées effectivement il a été
très apprécié par ses troupes donc il
donne l'image de quelqu'un de bien pour
résumer et bien on va voir ce à quoi il
va sûrement mais effectivement on va
voir ça quand je dis qu'on va voir ça
c'est on va voir s'il est candidat on va
voir s'il est quelqu'un de bien
ce dont a priori nous ne doutons pas on
nous changeons de sujet si vous le
voulez bien
demain sera examiné à l'assemblée
nationale une proposition de loi qui
émane de trois députés deux écologistes
est une ancienne de la république en
marche
l'idée est de permettre aux femmes
d'accéder à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse non pas pendant les 12
premières semaines mais pendant les 14
premières semaines donc deux semaines de
plus
là on est en dehors des cas de
d'interruption dit médicale de grossesse
où il n'y a pas de délai donc on
passerait de 3 mois à 3 mois et demi est
ce que ça vous paraît une bonne idée
claire chartier alors je crois que ça
met en lumière un vrai problème mais ça
n'apporte pas forcément une bonne
réponse
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que il
semble alors pourquoi pourquoi émettre
l'idée de rallonger ce délai c'est parce
que certaines femmes
en fait on arrive à dépasser la date
limite si je puis dire parce qu'elles
n'ont pas eu suffisamment accès au
parcours au parcours d'olive et j'ai
c'est à dire qu'elles n'ont pas eu les
informations qu'il fallait elles n'ont
pas eu le centre elle ne paye le rendez
vous avec le médecin elles ont dû
attendre trop longtemps pour avoir ce
rendez-vous ça dépend beaucoup des
régions concernées donc il ya beaucoup
de freins comme ça qui est qui qui
jalonnent le parcours est pour la pourra
certain nombre de femmes elles ne sont
pas très nombreuses en effet elle se
retrouve arriver aux douze semaines ou
c'est trop tard et donc elles ne peuvent
plus apporté donc le vraiment le
fondement de cette proposition c'est
celui là et là je trouve qu'il ya quand
même un petit problème dans le sens où
la vraie question c'est précisément
pourquoi ces freins existent c'est parce
que c'est même le vrai scandale quelque
part puisque ça fait 45 ans que nous
avons cette loi en france et que le
droit pour les femmes existent
de se faire avorter il n'est pas normal
que autant de chausse-trappes se
dressent sur leur chemin
dire que j'en ai cité quelques-uns mais
il ya aussi des médecins qui refusent de
pratiquer légers ils en ont parfaitement
le droit mais ils n'ont rien tu pas
alors qu'ils devraient le faire la femme
qui le demande vers un autre praticien
donc il ne donne pas les informations
requises donc il ya des services qui ont
été fermées il ya une vraiment une
carence de centre alors ça c'est dû
aussi à la restructuration des hôpitaux
qui ont fait que pour des raisons
budgétaires qui ont fait que certains
centres fermés notamment aussi les
maternités
donc il ya beaucoup comme ça de
d'éléments qui qui interpelle enfin je
veux dire ça n'est pas normal et ça mon
avis sur sa sur ce point là en amont il
faudrait comprendre au fait pourquoi ça
bloque autant en amont plutôt que de
repousser mes limites qui me semble pas
forcément la meilleure solution pourquoi
justin d'un mot c'est que évidemment là
cette limite la repousser cette limite
ça pose plusieurs problèmes
d'un point de vue médical ça n'est pas
tout à fait la même chose l'état disons
du futur bébé n'est pas le même à 12
semaines 2 semaines et à 14 on passe en
fait de l'embryon au foetus ce qui
évidemment engage des gestes même
médicaux différents à une formation est
elle différente
il ya un autre problème c'est que on
peut mener un dépistage précoce à cette
période sans avoir la garantie parce que
c'est encore trop tôt que ce dépistage
précoce d'une anomalie par exemple
génétique s'avère par la suite et donc
ça pourrait justifier une ivg alors qu
en fait l'enfant n'aurait pas ne
souffriraient pas de cette anomalie
ça c'est le problème médical puis un
problème politique c'est
qu'effectivement on peut se dire que ça
peut rouvrir vraiment un front bond de
deux confrontations éthique sur une
question sur laquelle la société s'était
retrouvée je veux dire la france s'est
retrouvée sur un consensus à 12 semaines
qui vont sembler à peu près convenir en
tout cas était véritablement acceptez
donc ça amènerait à rouvrir ce front là
ça me semble très très dommageable en ce
moment dans la france que nous
connaissons
durant les plusieurs mois pour une fois
je vais partager
david emmanuel macron si ce que dit le
canard enchaîné vrai puisque il est
apparemment il est très mécontent que
cette question ait été évoqué à
l'assemblée enfin dans une commission de
l'assemblée à la va-vite et et parce que
évidemment les comptes de ces décisions
extrêmement graves et et nous vivons des
temps où il est impossible à la
démocratie de s'exercer normalement donc
déjà ce genre de questions devaient être
évacués ont seuls le prétexte invoqué
est que le confinement enfin si j'ai
bien compris le début de l'histoire le
confinement présenter un certain nombre
d'indications
ou alors on doit le faire maintenant
parce que je voulais dire que même le
confinement n'avait pas empêché la
fortement vous disiez tout à l'heure où
il ya un certain nombre de choses tu
rappeler les jeunes femmes ne peuvent
pas avorter le fait est que en france je
sais pas si on peut s'en réjouir nous
sommes les champions du monde du nombre
d'avortements comparé aux autres pays en
un peu plus de 120 me est exactement
donc on a le sentiment que s'il ya une
gauche qui peut pas très de gauche sur
le plan social dont qui essaie de donner
des gages sur le plan sociétal
moi je voudrais simplement oui oui mais
oui aussi porté hyaric député
oui ça déraille oui ça dépend ce qu'on
appelle deux ligues en marche
non effectivement elle est partie un peu
de mal à créer enfin initialement les
tacots m avait pas de sensibilité de
gauche
peut-être que n'at on pas le curseur au
même endroit mais c est surtout il ya
deux points qui me paraissent quand même
assez flagrant alors 14 semaines
le professeur nisand de vous le disiez
vous même ça fait intervenir des
techniques tout à fait autre une femme
qui a fait une fausse couche on commence
à appeler ça d'ailleurs mort foetale in
utero à ce stade c'est que c'est c'est
loin d'être d'être anodin ça ressemble à
un vrai petit et le présent distante qui
disait dans la croix la tête est aussi
fier à ce stade donc on est obligé de
l'écraser soyons clairs donc comme
méthode c'est quand même extrêmement
spéciale il faut que les femmes le sache
par ailleurs je suis étonné que des
femmes se saisisse de cette question là
des femmes parce que vous savez qu'il ya
un vrai sujet autour de livet et là et
de tardif et qui existe dans d'autres
pays qui autorisent un
une ivg tardives c'est la connaissance
du sexe et vous savez que nous avons des
populations allochtones sur notre
territoire avant ça correspondait que le
que ça ne concernait que le pakistan et
l'inde maintenance accords et ça
concerne l'angleterre et ça sans doute
bientôt la france c'est à dire que ils
préfèrent avoir des garçons donc quand
ils ont la possibilité de connaître le
sexe de façon sûre avant de que la date
de lille ni vg sont interdites
eh bien on a des ivg en raison du sexe
et on sait que par exemple en angleterre
il ya une étude qui a été mou le fait
qu'ils montrent qu' il manque des filles
il manque des filles qui ont été sp
c'est ce qu'on peut appeler une sorte de
féminicide que était d avorter parce
qu'on ne voulait pas de filles donc il
me semble que c'est un sujet dont
quatorze semaines on sait de façon sur
le sexe ça me paraît être un sujet
curieux et la rafle âge montre productif
pour les femmes elle et des femmes qui
sont concernés sont la plupart du temps
mineurs est en situation de
vulnérabilité quand même c'est à dire
donc c'est pas tellement le profil bon
d'origine étrangère forcément et où tout
a une culture qui amènerait à chaud à
vouloir un sexe plutôt qu'un autre
c'est plutôt une question de
vulnérabilité sociale et qu'elles n'ont
pas eu accès donc à toutes sortes
d'informations ou toute sorte d'appui et
qu'elle se retrouve dans une situation
se retrouve coincé quoi donc c'est
plutôt ce type de profil qui est
concerné mais au moins autant je suis
très réservé en effet je pense que c'est
vraiment pas un combat à ouvrir la même
si c'est une vieille revendication a
vraiment qui ne date pas du confinement
autant je suis assez favorable alors
très favorable au fait les sages femmes
puissent pratiquer les ivg chirurgicales
comme on dit que ça ne soit pas que les
médecins parce que précisément comme il
ya une carence de médecins pour
pratiquer ces ivg ça fait partie des
obstacles que je vous avoue que tout à
l'heure
parce qu'ils sont pas assez formés parce
qu'il considère aussi que c'est pas
forcément très valorisant de pratiquer
une ivg
et pourquoi pas ils ont le droit le
problème c'est que donc il en manque de
confiance aussi
oui mais pas qu'eux mais ça peut bien
sûr donc ouvrir si vous la vision de loi
qui prévoit d'ouvrir cet acte la hausse
h va me paraître très bienvenu et je
suis pas non plus contre le fait de
lever l'objection de conscience pour les
médecins parce qu'en fait ils peuvent
déjà dire non du fait même parce que ils
sont médecins
et tout médecin peut refuser de
pratiquer en en vertu d'une position
devant vertu de sa conscience de refuser
de pratiquer un acte un acte médical
donc ya pas besoin de rajouter en fait
une clause de conscience donc là aussi
je trouve que c'est assez
enfin ça pourrait tout à fait pertinent
mais encore une fois sur le fond le vrai
combat à mener c'est cette montée en
puissance
finalement deux de ces obstacles et qui
ne s'observe pas qu'en france parce
qu'il ya quand même tout un courant et
ça aussi il faut le dire quand même
pourquoi mais tout tout à fait il faut
quand même replacer cela dans un
contexte général où lives et j'ai rien
pou européen et mondial
houle ivg et beaucoup remis en question
aujourd'hui aux états unis moi
énormément en europe de l'est en pologne
et en hongrie notamment
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya quand même un
mouvement de contestation et ses droits
des femmes et c'est sur ce coin là non
il s'est senti par des sites quand même
un qui répandait des informations
fausses sur les vg d'ailleurs ils ont
été fermés à la salle il ya aussi des
camps mais maxime reviendra l'été il y
en a des comptes des choses font rien
d'écrit gisant au milieu abriel ces
cycles a raconté quand même qu'eux aussi
ont pratiqué une ivg ou ne pourrai
jamais plus avoir d'enfant enfin des
balivernes de ceux de ce genre là
c'était de la délation mais il ya des
filières consacre donc ils disent sur
libéré qu'il n'y a pas de conséquences
psychologiques on peut le lire
eh bien il ya quand même quatre crois
que c'est un sondage à fouquières 92%
des français qui considèrent que ça
laisse des séquelles psychologiques et
les passionnés rythme oui mais ça passe
mais on peut imaginer qu'il y en a qui
l'envahît voilées sont juste des vies
ont subi vous savez très bien failli
vous aimez les
ouch et si vous arrivez sur salat souabe
assemblés les populations et moi je
crois au contraire que c'est très
intéressant parce que les servantes la
digue aux amis tous entre la perception
de la réalité qu'on les gens et 92%
c'est pas que l'électorat bruno
retailleau un sens nous avons dû gérer
ça veut dire mon petit savoir ce que ça
fait de se faire avant au bas j'espère
qu'à un homme suspect un homme spécial à
cinquante élèves de journée oui eh bien
ça on a imaginé un nombre de femmes
l'ont vécu dans leur chair moi je suis
là pour avoir interviewé une femme qui
allait l'écurie vga le disais c'est la
double peine parce qu'en réalité on le
vit mal psychologiquement et on n'a pas
le droit de dire qu'on le vit mal
psychologiquement ça si on le dit en
c'est malvenu c'est pas politiquement
correct donc moi je souffrais sur ces
sujets là on n'en parle pas du tout vous
disais que c'était des mineurs qui
seraient concernés par les 14èmes par
cet avortement à quatre semaines et bien
moi j'avoue que j'ai une grande peine
pour ces jeunes filles tout jeune fille
qui apporteront à 14 semaines d'un
enfant encore une fois déjà extrêmement
fort mais comment peut-on imaginer les
conséquences qu'ils connaissent à me le
dire
grâce à elles vont pas se faire avorter
vos détecteurs nous sommes d'accord on
est bien je vais bien et aucune ne lui
dis voilà sincèrement à la différence
vient de sa suppression à la fois
d'accord entre vous je vous propose de
prendre connaissance des remarques des
réactions de nos internautes on a posé
la question sur twitter faut-il allonger
le délai légal de lille et g et c'est
non à 69 % encore une fois ce n'est pas
un sondage mais la vie de nos
internautes pragma nous dit typiquement
ce sont des profils de femmes qui
actuellement vont se faire avorter en
espagne où s'est déjà autorisé jusqu'à
14 semaines
chardon bleu nous dit ils veulent même
aller jusqu'à neuf mois sous des
prétextes incroyable en soit c'est autre
chose
donc voilà c'est dans le projet de loi
dit de bioéthique qui a été adoptée en
première lecture à la fin du mois de
juillet où l'avortement pour des raisons
de détresse psychosocial je crois que
c'est ça le terme exact est
effectivement autorisé le sud on imagine
la boîte de pandore jusqu'à la veille de
l'accouchement merci beaucoup mesdames
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis et
très bonne soirée
[Musique]